uh all right we're going over to rod
rod is in rock hill south carolina rod
how can we help you today
hey chris hey ken thank you for taking
my call today sure buddy what's on your
mind
um i have a question for you and um it's
kind of a multi-part question but
um i want to know if i should put paying
off my student loans
uh to save an emergency fund for a
how baby do you owe in student loans
right uh 15
000 okay and what's your household
income buddy
um i got a new job last uh in last
month and right now it's sitting at
around 135k a year
okay and the 15 000 in student loan is
that all you owe or do you owe on
other things that's all i owe okay
well i'm going to tell you right now you
know i i'm never going to tell you and
we wouldn't hear
dave me or any of us and the money spoke
would never tell you
to not add to your family because of
debt
getting married adding to your family
those are decisions between you and your
wife
but i think it is definitely smart for
you to pile up some money
uh to be prepared uh for that and
then of course unleash all the focus and
power on attacking the debt once the
baby gets here yeah how much have you
guys
uh have you allocated in your minds or
at least on paper
that you need to save up for the baby
um she's actually pregnant now and um
because this was relatively new to me
um i didn't really think about
allocating until recently
and then i kind of sat down and
took taking a look at the numbers and
trying to get my
budgets uh set up with my new job
um so i guess
if if i stop paying or if i stop paying
student loans until
uh the baby's here i would allocate all
i guess all that money towards uh
the the birth which would uh well it's
not that you're necessarily gonna stop
paying on them you're gonna pay on them
yeah
i'm saying don't pay extra right that
allows you guys and i want you to get
what ken's trying to get you to do is to
get to a threshold of what
what your target is you don't have a
goal because you're not even sure
and so we don't want you to stop paying
on the student loans that's not
necessary i just
i'm trying to help you psychologically
get to a place where you feel much more
comfortable because you're scared right
now you're going to be a first time dad
we get it kristen have been there hey
how
how long how much further does she have
to go
she has about let's see five
or six months um but she doesn't have
health insurance either
okay um so that's another monkey range
they got from yeah so
well and that's a matter of you talking
to your your benefits professional find
out
when when you're eligible for that and
get her on yours as soon as possible
doesn't have a social security number
she's an immigrant so
um we are kind of
which which makes this question a little
more complicated um and i've
tried to look at different insurance
policy plans
um but they all require a social
security number
that changes this question yeah it does
and and here's here's the thing that i'm
going to want you to do
i want you to go to dave ramsey.com i
want you to get connected with one of
our insurance elps
uh because i am not sure of the process
or what has to be done or what can be
done
but i know they will be um and so again
go to daveramsey.com get connected to an
insurance eop
and begin to kind of walk through that
because you may be
facing a larger dollar amount than
you're even anticipating
uh so now i can understand his
tentativeness uh with this and so
instead of wondering let's get the
details let's get the information and
the facts
so we can deal in knowns not speculate
all right so to that end you're the
money guy
uh i know the baby steps all right but
i've got a question on this
because i think there's other people
that are in the situation if we find out
or if he finds out
that this is going to be completely out
of pocket because i think that's what
he's worried about
it feels like it could be right so let's
say it's a large number that
you know he's not sure what that is and
they go you got to pay for the birth and
the hospitalization all out of pocket
and he doesn't have it that we we are
okay in that situation where he's
where he's got to figure something out
yeah well i mean not pausing the debt
payments but what does he do
well the reality is is in most scenarios
where people run into emergencies and
they don't have it
it's not that you're paying it up front
but you are going to have to pay yeah it
becomes another one it becomes another
debt
that's exactly right and all you would
do is approach it in the debt snowball
form
uh so it would fall if he had 15 000 in
student loans
and the birth ends up being 25 grand
he's going to attack
student loans then go down and attack uh
the the hospital next
right and so that's typically the
approach with that uh rod thanks for
reaching out
uh and i think you guys getting the
answers uh and i think you go in
together
once you talk to this insurance elb if
you do a face-to-face meeting
that way you are everyone's hearing the
information and can get all the
questions answered
uh but that's the approach my friend but
i do want to let people know
if you're out there and you're pondering
getting married and you say well
i've got debt or maybe your fiance has
that and you think
we're not getting married till we get
debt-free uh that's not something that
we would tell you
okay that's not something that we we say
that's something you can decide
uh but the most important things is that
you're in the same page
on the same page with getting married or
adding to the family
i think it's important just to think
those things through and to talk it out
so you can know exactly where you are
and where you're headed